[Music]
we all know New York is the Big Apple
New Orleans the Big Easy Chicago the
Windy City and Las Vegas Sin City but
did you know Houston is known as space
city it all began almost six decades ago
when NASA decided to open the manned
spacecraft Center they're putting
Houston on the map in a state where size
matters Houston is the top dog of Texas
the biggest city with the busiest port
in the nation its skyscrapers reach for
the heavens boasting an identity built
on trying to get us there
how much did the culture of NASA seep
into the framework so to speak of the
city itself
I think it's huge Pulitzer Prize winner
Alex Stuckey joined the Houston
Chronicle to cover mission moon you can
look everywhere and their space stuff I
mean there's space murals everywhere
there's even a moonwalking cow at Bush
Intercontinental Airport and not one but
two celestial inspired sports teams the
Astros and the Rockets Houston is among
the first words uttered in outer space
historian Douglas Brinkley wrote
American moonshot I mean NASA looks at
Euston as the Vatican of space but the
Vatican of space had very humble
beginnings
according to Rice University professor
Melissa Kean Houston began its life as a
muddy swampy mosquito infested yellow
fever trap Keane pulled photos from her
archives of Houston at the turn of the
20th century this is what will become
the Ship Channel later Buffalo Bayou was
the locus of the growth of the city but
it started off as essentially a big wide
creek city leaders envisioned expanding
that Creek into a 25 mile long shipping
lane from the Gulf Coast port of
Galveston which was leveled by the
nation's deadliest natural disaster in
1900 and the Houston leadership took
advantage of this to do this audacious
construction project so without this you
wouldn't
have the infrastructure for NASA to be
here that's right NASA was looking for
the right stuff a city with elite
universities to support research and
training a modern airport and a warm
climate for working outdoors a
year-round by 1960 Houston had it all
plus some good old boy politicians to
boot you had to have political clout and
Houston had it in abundance in abundance
next month
we'll have a leadership in space which
you wouldn't have without Alba Thomas
and so will this city Congressman Albert
Thomas controlled NASA's budget it's
chaired the House Appropriations
Subcommittee Vice President Lyndon
Baines Johnson was also on board and
construction magnate George our Brown
Kennedy barely won Houston in 1960 he
would need to win it in 1964 and pouring
hundreds of millions of dollars into
Houston was good new frontier politics
NASA announced that the manned space
center was going to be located in
Houston on September 19 1961 and every
newspaper in town the front page was
covered where space city we are now
fighting the Russians from Houston it
was spectacular a year later President
Kennedy was at Rice teeing up the
mission we used to go to the moon and
all of a sudden we felt like a young and
vibrant and important place we're
building satellites our experiments are
going up in space Rice University was
all into donating land on the outskirts
of the city for NASA's manned space
center and the people who worked there
three years later there's a small city
there and what you can't see in this
picture is all around it residential
areas begin springing up like mushrooms
which became home to the mercury and
Apollo astronauts including the
soon-to-be firsts Armstrong Aldrin and
Collins it was an oil and gas town it
was petroleum once NASA comes to euston
everything changes every business wants
to be part of this
moon energy no we're more boldly than
baseball's newest treasure the Astrodome
the world's first multi-purpose domed
stadium built by the team who'd already
swapped out their old colt 45 s moniker
it's here the Apollo 11 crew were
welcomed back to their official hometown
homecoming hosted by Frank Sinatra
himself fifty years after the Eagle
landed NASA hopes to return this time as
a jumping-off point to go even further
into our solar system people around my
age they want to go to Mars I've
interviewed so many people as I said I'm
not getting married I'm not having kids
because I want to go to Mars what sparks
that kind of curiosity there's a little
bit of wanting to be the first I am we
had in the sixties the 60s Douglas
Brinkley says was a time of monumental
change change personified in a single
American city that dare to dream big
this may be the age of Neil Armstrong
we're living in right now I mean that's
how large breaking Earth's gravitational
pull is so years from now euston may be
seen as the great American city where
first time Earthlings from euston were
able to project to the solar system and
beyond